everybody doing I got the after lunch
lull so let's see if I can keep you guys
entertained or fixated a bit okay it
looks better here than it does on my
laptop so I'm gonna follow so today's
lesson is actually gonna be a little bit
recovering the pipe torch but we're
gonna start off with some very very
basic things just kind of find out
what's going on to the hood and then
from there we're gonna dive deeper into
some other topics like CNN transfer
learning especially if we have enough
time it will actually cover some RN ends
alright so I want everyone to please go
to this website collab without research
not Google calm because we're you're
gonna basically be running the exact
same things I do a 90 minute tutorial
where you just watch me you guys will
fall asleep so so if you guys funnel
long you guys could actually keep this
at the end or you can pull from my
github by the by the time the I could by
tomorrow have everything nice and ready
right now this is just sort of the
hands-on part but I'll put up solutions
etc if you guys want to go so the lab
research Google comm so you need to have
a Google account but I'm guessing
99.999% of you do good when you go on
there you're gonna see some sort of web
that looks kind of like this see if I
can make this
so raise raise your hand if you're out
the screen here all right let's give it
a couple seconds for those who are
already there type in this HTTP colon
double backslash github.com / Robert
Dodge Alvarez so it's it's github.com
obviously but you have to put the HTTP
and then my username at github which is
Robert - Alvaro once you've got that if
you hit tab it should generate you might
get this this happens whenever there's a
lot of tutorials going on it thinks
everyone's trying to hit the the github
API so just authorize it if you got that
error message and it's literally hi
torch tutorial
if you have any questions please raise
your hand and the first five minutes
we're gonna start getting set up so how
did I get the what good thing here if it
doesn't pop up automatically go to file
open if you hit tab it should
automatically populate the repository
like you it'll have actually some of my
other repositories but oh then see if
you could have to like log in to your
github account yeah yeah then try to put
connector
out of curiosity I mean here are
students that at a university here so I
don't live here anymore but I'm actually
from my hands so I went that by you got
my two bachelor's and my master's there
did you go to high school
yeah daebak's I went to sunset yeah like
I wasn't born here but I'm pretty much
pretty much like I moved here when I was
five years old and this man actually
came literally just for this conference
and to see my family and I'm gonna be my
name in less than 24 hours that's pretty
brutal in terms of flight but I came for
the conference and to see my family
all right and then we'll see you here
right just click on this guy Pytor
tutorial hands on should love this
webpage you know I prefer standing and
this thing makes me feel like I have to
sit okay just want to take a ticket I
just I don't want to I don't really
apologize for the there we go that's
they're gonna look a little better I'm
pretty much zoomed out a whole whole
heck here all right
where's your hands when you guys are
here or I could at least see this a
little less starting to get a bit more
alright we're almost close we're pretty
close to starting them for those who are
already here though so there's gonna be
a difference between installing PI parts
locally and doing this on collab right
so if I had asked you to do this all
locally you have to go through the
continent install or install from source
make sure and you guys would all have to
pull from my github repo up it's gonna
take too long so it's a lot faster to go
to here once we are connected click on
the runtime change runtime type and see
here that there's now the option for a
GPU alright so one of the things that we
want to use PI torch for is the fact
that it's GPU accelerated so we don't
have to use the CPU for computation we
can actually do some of the cores from
the graphical processing unit and Google
gives us to us for free the so I'm gonna
hit cancel
unfortunately on my screen it looks
quite small you got a runtime change
runtime type and well and then at
hardware accelerator add GPU not CPU
all right do that good save I'm going to
first see if I can change the
Preferences here this is really
see if this is better it's like
they're all the built-in retina
mm yeah that's actually that might be
the best because now I can actually
bring this up yeah looks pretty crappy
here all right I'm gonna go back to that
previous one apologize for all the
issues sometimes it's
that's the go to these headaches at
first and then deal with things later
there we go that's better right right
move them or
okay so what did I say to change go to
runtime change runtime type
and make sure that GPU on the hardware
accelerator
all right it's safe and then as I was
mentioning to install PI torch on Google
it actually has to deal with this small
little command your face it's much
easier to cut and paste and try to do
the whole kind of install Google
actually provides that for you whenever
you try to connect to whenever you try
to import torch so just run that very
first line if if you haven't run
anything you can just hit unclick the
reset run time but if you don't all
right that one's done and then if you
click on the next line this is an issue
that I have with CIL that doesn't work
on Google collab so if you don't run
this you're gonna get an error when
we're going to the transfer learning
part so make sure you run both these
lines it'll it does it just like Jupiter
notebook it doesn't mean seriously I
just realized that
I'm gonna restart mine just look you
don't have to restart yours I realized
that mine actually was so for my
previous connection
all right so if you guys wanted to
install condoms right and self by
Georgian condo you go through that
little thing right there on your local
browser on your local machine book we
don't have to do that right because this
is the fourth you guys want to play with
this later on if you have a MacBook you
can't use the GPU etc etc unless you
install from source and you have a GPU
so most of time if you install locally
you're only going to be using the CPU
well for what we're gonna be doing today
right as long as you this is a PI data
conference as a Python conference we're
gonna be importing some of the usual
suspects and things that we're gonna be
having to do generally right import our
OS some requests zip files of things
that do handle images obviously numpy
and pandas but but here's the good stuff
right so this is the reason you guys are
all here so pi torch gets the libraries
called torch instead
that's the original name from it so it's
import torch and then imports dot and n
which is a neural net module as I'm n
right and then we're gonna down be
importing Auto grad which is the
backpropagation automatic
differentiation or automatic gradient
some other the functional that I'll
starting talking about in a bit more
context and then from torch vision so
like vision like computer vision
packages and then kind of the usual
stuff right my have plot live in line
right
and then all of the data lives here
right this is a link to a Dropbox that
will automatically download all the data
that we need today and that should be
fairly quickly because we're doing a
network to network transfer instead of
from network down to your laptop
okay this might take a little bit longer
for you I already have this downloaded
alright everyone's still not here
[Music]
anyways one for the github.com slash
Robert - Alvarez so it's my name Robert
- Alvarez not understory
all right everyone
good to go awesome all right so now we
could actually get started we've done
now we've got all the data locally we've
been we've installed a pie chart we've
got all of the libraries imported so
we're now we're gonna start so what is
pike talks right so PI torch is there's
two things right it's it's a replacement
for numpy using GPUs which in my much
longer version of this tutorial
we would cover in a little bit more in
depth and then the other one is PI
torches of nice deep learning like a
flexible deep learning platform using
Python obviously so we're gonna be
focusing on the second one which I guess
is the reason why you got here you don't
care how to use numpy on a GPU so we'll
skip that part although if you guys want
the longer version of it it'll be posted
on my github tomorrow I just didn't want
it to clot I didn't want you to be
clicking on the wrong way right but to
talk about PI torch we started talking
about pencils right so what are 10 well
know what a matrix is we all know what
an image is and well a matrix is just a
sort of a 2d tensor and then an image is
really three matrices stacked on top of
each other you've got especially if it's
color image so you've got the typical
red the red matrix the green matrix and
the blue matrix is what we call an RGB
image and when you stack those three
together you get a 3d tensor and that is
what we call a tensor and tensors can
actually go as many dimensions as we
want a 1d tensor is a vector a through D
tensor is a matrix 3d tensor is an image
for D etc etc etc alright so we've got
this typical picture of grumpy cat
grumpy cat although one you see it on
your screen it looks like one single
image but really behind behind the
scenes there there are actually three
different matrices telling me the color
coordination each of these and we're
going to need to be doing a lot of
manipulations on these because we will
see that images in particular do really
well in in neural nets because we're
going to try to find patterns in them
and we're going to be since these are
all tensors
inputs going to be a tensor and then we
could do a lot of manipulation behind
the scenes using another clock all right
so here we be sort of an example of the
redneck reach the green matrix and then
the blue matrix in the back here's a
nice little visualization of what these
tensors look like in several different
dimensions right I have it has explained
before 1d tensor is just a vector 2d
tensors and matrix the 3d tensors is a
cube right but then you can keep on
extrapolating so on and so forth so for
T tensors really is a vector of these
cubes etc etc it's be very careful when
we import really large tensors though
because they take up a lot of memory so
you'll see one special when we do some
of these image classification tasks we
actually really downsized the quality
image quite dramatically because
otherwise we could run into serious
computational issues or memory issues
so starting off with neural nets looks
like you guys are all familiar or no
I've heard of a neural net right so no
net and this is basically the most
common one this is what we call a
perceptron so you've got some inputs
right so these are the inputs being fed
these inputs each have a specific weight
so for example you know do we want to
weight this input stronger to make sure
that whether we activate this neuron all
right so this is think of it the typical
single neuron that's coming on with some
attribute values right so you know did I
get did I burn myself on the oven right
so I've got some sort of sensory input
once it crosses some threshold the
neuron activates and I get a reaction
out right so this is the very basic
thing you know if we stack these many
many on top of each other and wide we
start getting what is called this is
just a very basic one and
but it really is is just linear
regression it's just a linear take all
these inputs you multiply them the
weights summing up and find out if you
above some threshold or not if you want
if I talked about activation or not
within general it's just a linear
regression right but we could have more
of these but we also want to find out
sometimes if we've been activated or not
right so if in the in the flight I
showed you before it was just a linear
regression it sums up the weights times
the input and it just left that number
out but there are times we want to say
hey did we cross some thorough threshold
for example did we are we positive now
or are we negative and if so then we can
use some sort of other like squashing
function or also called activation pumps
and say hey now that this input is above
zero let's set it to be one going
forward so that we've activated the
neuron if we didn't if it's less than
zero we just say hope now just flatten
it and to be exclusively zero and it
didn't get activated right so this is
very similar how we think the brain
works
which is why called neural nets but I
don't think that's the case but as those
help ratings in terms of doing
classification punches so if you're
looking at like a fraud detection
algorithm we really wanted to you know
we're going to take in a whole bunch of
inputs pass it through a net and
determine whether or not this person
committed fraud or not so it's gonna be
a 0 or 1 so ultimately we're gonna try
to pass it through this neuron that and
say hey or once we squash it where is
this boundary to determine whether or
not we're 1 or 0 right Prader now what
but the way that we've done this is
right so we need to leave a train this
way which used to be initialized to wait
that's some sort of value and propagate
through this net or through this
perceptron and determine whether or not
we got close to what the training data
tells us right we're always gonna be
looking at pretty native just we don't
create a neuron that that automatically
happens to have the right weights right
so we start off with some training data
we pass it through this neuron that you
do a forward pass saying hey we're going
to initialize the weights at zero we're
gonna pass it through this net we're
going to activate all of these things
and then we're gonna look at the output
is the output what we expected no well
how far off were we and let's propagate
back and then change that so that we can
continue to get update those weights to
get closer and closer to the true output
and we'll go into much more detail about
that later ok so you're gonna be
computing right to initialize the Vake
for each of the samples right compute
the output click calculate the error and
then update the date the weights and we
update the weights by using the new
weight is the old way plus some gradient
or some learning rate times the gradient
of the air
so going back to this right so this is
kind of how we fit a model right with
the same same way we've got our inputs
or outputs or learned weights and the
algorithm is the same we're now just
going to be a little bit more
mathematical about this right so we're
gonna have some sort of loss function
right whether it's cross-entropy loss or
being squared error loss and then we
want to update to what the weights using
popuiation so in this case it works this
is a mean squared error loss so we say
hey what is the difference between my
predictive value and my predict and my
actual value square that difference and
say we want to minimize that as much as
possible this is sort of like what what
you're minimizing an ordinary linear
regression is block or normal in these
squares regression and here we've sort
of slightly change the notation around
it's a it's a minus sign but it's got
the learning rate so what you want to
modify this learning rate was one of the
leaders you can modify a neural net is
that learning rate if you make it too
big you might actually over jump the
next step where you're just supposed to
be going but so let's start off with a
basic example if you click on that
little line here it should automatically
download what we're gonna do is create
the most complicated adding machine you
can write so here is the very first time
or writing popeye short code right so
our model right is gonna get neural net
sequential so basically a neural net
sequential is gonna be saying hey do
these things in sequence right pretty
straightforward and we're gonna do
something very simple we're gonna take
the two inputs right so we're gonna take
the two numbers and we're gonna get one
output and we want to going to randomize
the weights and we want to find out how
long will it take for it to Train where
they can add two numbers enough right we
know we can do this kids can do this
this was actually pretty slow to do well
you'll see how long it takes
so the optimizer we're going to be using
the Adam which is sort of like a
variation of the classic gradient
descent and our criterion our loss
criterion is the mean squared error loss
right
want to find out what is the different
the squared difference between our
predicted value and our actual value
right and if your print model it
actually tells you what are the layers
of each neuron that remember that we're
doing this very very basic said in
number features out features we don't
want to set the bias to be true so
basically we could have added a bias
term this is the same thing as adding a
constant in the regression but we're
going to avoid that for now just because
we know it's not necessary so we're
gonna find that we're gonna train this
model we're going to go through 10,000
samples we're gonna create a random
number right so we're gonna generate
random numbers on the interval of zero
to four we're gonna add them together
and that's gonna be our target made
that's what you see here our data is the
actual variable X that we generated and
then our target is just going to be well
x0 plus x1
very very easy but it's a nice little
illustration because it abstracts the
way of what we're actually trying to
program it just focus on the code so the
outputs gonna be well what is the model
for that data and then the loss is going
to be the output on the target and then
we want to append the loss and this
optimizer the zero gradient so every
time I do a forward pass through the
neural net I'm sorry a backward pass is
a neural net I calculate the gradient
and then I need to zero out that
gradient so that I lose it from memory
and does the forward path again sort of
from scratch with the new updated
weights and goes back all right so we
got the loss top backward so this is
where I if we had covered sort of the
num high GPU version you would have cut
up a little bit more of this topic but
and pretty much the optimizer needs to
get it's a gradient zeroed out then we
do the backward step to calculate that
gradient and then we do the step forward
that's all we're doing here so
press play should be fairly quick ran
and now this is just a plot of this
so our very very slow adding machine
took almost 2,000 samples for it to
finally figure out that it was trying
what the weights were supposed to be for
each of the faculty so we started off
with some random numbers calculated a
gradient that gradient was off did it
again right updated that gradient did it
again and again again it took almost
2,000 samples for it to realize that the
way students just been able but this is
what it's doing
no matter the task right we could have
been doing this in image recognition we
could have been doing this in like a
language model thanks
so I'm not distracting the way all of
that and they're saying hey what we're
going to try to do is just the backward
pass
oh sorry is the update of the weights
[Music]
yeah what did that do here
and this is the model I'll put it right
so you've got on well it's hard to see
on the overlapping there's actually the
red dots which are the predictions and
the blue line which is the actual so we
generated data on 0 4 that's where we
had our training data right
as with everything that we're gonna be
doing machine learning we have our
training data and then we have things
that we're trying that are outside of
our training our sort of validation set
so we want to say hey yeah we've got our
accuracy rate here and we're doing well
but we know that this is sort of a
contrived mall right but we could start
doing a little bit of an things we can
start adding nonlinear activation
function which we'll see in just a
second to see how that actually affects
and particularly you'll see that it
starts to get the data right the
training data right but it starts to
then perform differently outside of that
set because it thinks it's got some
nonlinear qualities to it although it
was able to get rectified down that so
that was that path right so this is the
representation of a feed-forward neural
net right so we've got our inputs here
passing it to our first layer so
everything between a 1 and a 5 I'm sorry
2 & 5 are our hidden layers this is our
input layer and 6 is our upper layer and
these biases where what happens when you
set bias equals to true so this is just
sort of saying hey we should have some
maybe some activation to your signal so
for every single one of these inputs I
pass these through remember every single
one of these blue lines has a weight
associated to it so we've got weights
here wait here wait here wait here and
weights there at the end so for every
single time we go forward we multiply
all these eights and when we come back
we say hey how much were we off by there
at the output update those weights then
how much were we off by between these
two layers update that layer of weights
right using the previous the ones that
you had from the output so this is what
we call a feed-forward back propagation
net we're gonna be going forward through
the neural net we find out what that
error is and then we go back
they're hidden like well that's what we
did in that sequential so if I go back
you so the input layer and the Apple
layer are always defined right the first
layer of the neural net says tells you
how big your input is and then the last
layer of your neural of your hidden
layer tells you how big the output
should be so in this case when we said
here I'm getting two things as an input
because sorry two things as an input
because this is the first layer the
first hidden layer so what how many
things come before me that's my input
size and since it's also the last layer
the last hidden layer they should tell
me how many things I need to output
alright so there are many different
types of activation functions and high
torch has even more than these I kind of
know that mentioned the most common ones
that you've got your sigmoid right your
rel you is the the most common one but
so basically relly just says if you're
positive give me your value back if
you're negative you've got squashed to
zero leaky relly has a little bit of
sort of leakage on the negative side and
then the sigmoid is it's a standard
sigmoid curve or logistic function right
let's see what happens when we start
using these rights because if I stacked
30 layers of N n dot linear without any
nonlinear activation function I have
just done your regression there's
nothing different right it's just now a
whole bunch of different ways I could
have combined all those weights together
and had a different weight and it's just
linear regression but the interesting
happens the interesting thing happens
when we start using nom anyway and
neural nets are turing-complete so
that's like I don't know make sure I use
a right there they can they can
approximate any function that's the way
right so then taking approximate your
function they have to be able to do
nonlinear functions as well so that's
where with this sort of plate comes into
effect then you'll see this some of the
other things that we can do for
specifically for image as we get that
far down the left so again we have now
just added more complexity to our adding
machine nothing different here we start
off with our layer we start off with two
notes right so our input fill the same
we're gonna take in those two numbers
and then we say hey give me those two
numbers and then output 20 with
different weights associated for each
right so we go from 2 in the beginning
so in in this case of this
representation we would go from 2 to 20
on the first layer
and then take that output pass it
through a sigmoid it does not take any
parameters because this basically gives
you the same input as outputs I'd say
just pass it through this function and
then again we're gonna say give me some
more linear features squash it again
more linear features wash it again and
at the very end I need to go from them
the size that I had before and then one
being the output that I want
all right so I always like to plot this
just so you can see exactly what the
steps are being done in the neural net
so there's in that graph that I showed
you before there isn't that
representation of the squashing function
so we pass it through a neural net and
say hey were these cells activators are
these neurons activated via some sort of
squashing funds or activation function
yes pass them on to the next one
so we run this again should take me
really quick
and because of the nominee reality
aspect remember before when we just had
linear it took a little bit less than
2,000 steps for it to finally balance
out but by adding some non-linearity we
were sort of confusing the model a
little bit right and then saying all
right now it's going to take us a little
longer so it took almost 3,000 samples
or 4,000 samples to figure out how to
add two numbers so these things are done
but they're very efficient they worked
very well in this case just so you could
have set it to false anyway what it
would find out is because it now has to
do three weights work so if I had Bias
equals false it just goes input to the
weights if I have bias equals true I
have an a.1 as an input as well and then
sorry as a as one of the parameters and
it needs to realize that that weight is
zero so I'm I have I add an extra weight
to my model add an extra layer of
complexity
but so we're doing fairly well on the
actual place where we have training data
but this is one that doesn't generalize
well because what we really have is
linear data but we're trying to
approximately where the nonlinear
function so we're gonna be getting off
on places where it it thinks Oh from
here on out you must be a nonlinear
since I'm a nonlinear function I can
sort of rectify you as much as possible
where I have the training data if I had
I had made this wider the same thing
would it happened I would have got it
rectified a little bit longer but I'm
still gonna start dropping off in the
tails if you see this actually looks
sigmoid I'll go through this one briefly
this is the exact same model but instead
of a sigmoid I just passed the Reilly
and put up my screen brightness because
I can't see anything when we start
getting this typical flat and then so we
start seeing some little patterns of
what the activation function is doing
and sort of the last basic one before we
get into the really fun stuff right well
it's pretty easy to teach a machine to
add two numbers kind of the first things
I ever did with computers can we teach
it to draw and if so how long does it
take it for us to teach it to draw a
circle so what we're trying to make it
for the math poking here we're trying to
make it given us approximation to to
this matrix right it's a rotation matrix
can we use by using a neural net
generate a rotation matrix with giving
it enough training create a custom
activation function to do just about
anything since that you are the power of
the neural network is the computation is
really done by the that yeah but you
also have a lot of interactions between
the users right so you could have a very
there are many different activation
functions you can use in some work
better than others right so for example
you had a like max pooling and cnn's and
now batch norm seems to be the nicer one
when you get a new one sexy activator
well yeah yeah and so it does do a lot
because the reason why is because that's
what gives you that non-linearity right
so if there's there's only so many
functions I can generate with values
right so if I will right like I was
mentioned before a neuron that can
generate any type of function as long as
I have the right activations but without
the right activations limiting myself
right in place okay I'm having one arm
behind tied behind your back right
unless you get the right activation
function becomes really difficult to get
the solution to the problem at hand
activation function so you I would start
off with something basic right to see
where well what is it that it's getting
wrong right is an image test there's a
whole different thing altogether but in
the image taxis usually want to do some
sort of convolution some sort of max
cooling batch norm many layers of
convolution I forgot things that
different sizes at different scales and
actually go into a little bit of detail
than that later on but but yeah you are
right
without the activation function this is
just linear regression and I could only
get lines up so but it is the workhorse
yeah this very first part is just
basically boilerplate code of plotting
and training a model right so that just
kind of wrote it all in the function so
you can skip it for now and then here it
is right so this is the first time we're
actually declaring a class in PI tours
right before I just said hey the model
gets and in dot sequential and that's
very basic for a simple model 99% of the
time you're gonna be doing things that
and in dot sequential can't handle like
convolutions that can't handle so you'll
have to start creating your own classes
so class rotations or whatever my neural
net whatever it is that you would like
to call it you pass it the NN module and
a beak and it harriet's from the
superclass right so it's going to
inherit its initialization from
rotations that self and then I need to
reap declare each of the layers here
right so I've got self dot layer one is
n n dot sequential I know that
once was basic but I wanted to show you
what have like this is now the very
first time so I'm taking the very basic
one and defining it as a class as we
then get being changed the complexity of
it so layer one is a sequential you've
got a linear layer got one input
remember I'm only passing it theta and I
want to get it the four different
rotation than both the four things on
the matrix so one layer the number of
nodes that I'm going to be trying out
then I'm gonna squash it using a
nonlinear activation because otherwise I
couldn't generate a circle and then
again pass it to a linear and get me
back and then this is the forward layer
so this is the certain this is something
you have to define in Python so once
I've defined my layer itself I must
define the forward path how is it that
it's going through the forward steps and
then one of the nice things about PI
tours is that I don't have to define the
back propagation it already knows what
are the gradients associated with this
forward pass so I don't need to declare
that but in this case it's very straight
forward we're going to be slowly
increasing in complexity our outage is
gonna be this self dot layer one so this
layer one is this entire node like this
entire sequence of things so pass it
through here in a forward step and it
automatically knows what the great unit
then I'm gonna apply my model right it's
just gonna be the class of rotations my
optimizer is not changing my criterion
is not changing and then I'm gonna train
it through this should have told you to
run this while I was talking I should
have started running in the sauce
[ __ ] in text we take a little bit
longer it takes a couple minutes
alright not a winter like thirty seconds
or so
the difference between the point so
remember I take in a theta and it
generate an XY write x equals cosine
theta y equals sine theta and then I
find out well given this given the real
theta and these generated ones from the
weights how far off am i from from that
in a sort of euclidean sense so you
clean that since with Miami squared
error loss good person I have to think
about to say and this does take longer
because remember we're not adding two
numbers you'll see a lot of messiness
and the last function but you'll see it
starts to get pretty good and you'll
notice that in the next line I sort of
start teasing like will a deeper network
work better and this is where we go into
the topic of if I add more layers I'm
adding more complexity in terms of
computation but I'm able to get a lot of
that fine nuance that I just don't get
with a lesser amount of layers
defying interlayer neither clucks and
that you belong to another class and you
just defined
when this is done running I'm actually
going to run the next one as well for
that while I start talking through the
information you'll see how how much
better it gets just by adding a few more
layers right so this is just where yeah
everyone's we've got a linear or sigmoid
back to linear if we've then chain these
in similar ways that we could have added
different types of activations so here
we go
I mean first run this one you guys can
run it as well but well I think that's
next need there we go so this is my last
one so remember before when we had the
the adding the two numbers it was pretty
much dropped off right away
well now I'm trying to got to few things
correct and I start notice that well I
do okay this is actually me trying to
trace out because otherwise I could keep
information from the previous gradient
and so now I'm at a new location I don't
want to have information about the
gradient at a previous location where I
was at and I'll have a little visual
like how it's really going down this
gradient descent and I don't want to
have information about a gradient not a
position that is not where I'm at
there's really the gist of it
so we only generated our random numbers
our training data only comes from 0 to 2
pi but it's actually able to do yeah not
great but you start seeing that it's
able to start start extrapolating
elsewhere rights and this is one of the
things we always use it on training data
no matter what we're looking on then we
basically say how well is it doing
outside of that and if I go into a much
deeper network I may be actually able to
get as many rotations I don't want only
feeding it data between 0 and 2pi right
but then all the food competitions that
complexity increases dramatically but
pretty nice that I can actually generate
rotation matrices using 1x or do I have
today sorry oh yeah I wants to pass it
from before this is why it's going so
slow you change the texture which this
should actually run much faster
I was wondering I was like why is it so
slow I must have missed that elsewhere
in the training function there it's in
the so when I define like rotations in
like here are the helper functions one
of them has CUDA is false CUDA is the
GPU it should be true yeah well well the
the plot circles I think it just needs
to go from CUDA to numpy further plot so
I think that one is correct but
but we're almost done and then
everywhere else is definitely hazardous
and you'll see a dramatic increase in
speed especially when are we going to
sort of the CNN where your own weight
I do 60,000 images and the same time
that I do in half the time or a court of
the time that I do rotation so this is
my actual this is the dip where I
generated data from 0 to PI and now with
a deeper neural net I'm actually able to
get really good position from 2 pi to 4
PI even though I never find any of that
information right I start doing terrible
at 4 PI to 6 pi but if I go deeper and
deeper and deeper I could start
generating unit circles no matter what
fader gets passed to me without even
having to do obviously some conversion
to bring it back down to 0 2 pi
so going back to your question you had a
you know why do I want to zero
ingredients so I'll first talk about
this graph and then I'll talk about what
the paragraph on topping it is so every
time we start off in their own that we
initialize some weights this heat map
you see here this sort of contour map is
the sort of space in which my function
lives it's going to have its valleys
it's gonna have its Peaks and I'm trying
to find the minimum right we're always
trying to find the minimum of our
function which is where we're going to
have the least amount of loss the
highest precision etc but I do that sort
of doing I don't wanna say a random walk
but it's a bit by a gradient descent
right so I start off here I find out
where is the steepest part where I'm
standing so you could think of it like
if you've ever been climbing you're like
okay this is steep I don't want to go
that way well this thing says yes I do
want to go that way but in the other
direction because it's going to get me
lower as fast as possible so then I
start jumping around here but the thing
is once I was here this piece has a
gradient that corresponds to that level
so once I go here I need to forget the
gradient there and say ok now I'm at a
new spot what is my gradient here where
should I go next and then I do this sort
of looks like a random walk but it's not
and ultimately until ultimately I find
my minimum but as you guys all know
there are many places where we can find
local minima and not the global minima
so we need to so one of the things that
we talked about this Bayesian approach
is that you would train multiple models
at once with different initializations
so then say let's run a whole bunch of
these with different parameters and find
out where is the goal of the one instead
of running the same model over and over
and potentially getting to the same
local optima every single time train
them with different run musicians so
that I could have started here and maybe
gone through this minimum instead of
that minimum
shortest path they don't like a 3d like
space it's not shortest path but it's
trying to find the steepest descent but
the steepest descent and if I end up
going over here now once I reach this
valley I can't get out of there anymore
because everywhere the steepest place is
where I'm already at well this minimum
is wearable yet oh this is from a
different image this is just this is
basically your features right so so the
two features and then your loss function
it's hard to draw in 4d or 5d load-out
so in this case we would say hey here
are two features this is what the
contour well why our loss function looks
like it's a contour plot let's try to
find out the the minimum as a surface
plot sorry
sort of jumping quickly we went from
adding numbers drawing circles to go
straight to image recognition so this is
a fairly big jump but first we're gonna
talk about image recognition and we're
gonna do this because in pie charts you
can already download faintly so-called
famous models right you can download
ResNet you can have it be pre trained
you can download c4 which is the one
we're gonna look at first but to do
image recognition we really are going to
be passing it through a similar neural
net right it's not going to be the
typical hidden layer like we saw above
where it was just wait because we need
to do a few different types of
manipulations to them we're going to do
convolutions so this image here of this
car right and if you notice it's stacked
because it's an RGB at the tensor this
convolution starts looking at it in the
very first layer convolution start
looking for lines right whether it's
straight lines or diagonal lines that
really just starts looking for line okay
if I only have a one layer Liril at the
most I could kind of do is I'm sorry one
layer convolution the millisecond fire
do is start trying to find things that
look like lines or untagging
alright so this is why a one layer and
that works fairly well with M&S the
handwriting dataset this is like but as
I go deeper right so this pooling is
gonna start getting me things at
different zoom in rates right so at
different of various levels of
magnification right so this max pooling
might give me a zoom in on an ear or on
the tire whatever then I do more
convolution giving me nonlinear features
and I'll show you there's a great
article called visual is that visual is
visualizing and understanding
convolutional nets or convolutional
neural nets that has a great image great
image of what each layer in the
convolution does and first layer is
always basic lines second layer starts
getting a little bit more nonlinear
third fourth fifth layer you actually
start to resemble things like dogs
humans etcetera so we do the hidden
layer part then we usually flatten this
out through a fully connected path and
then we pass it through an activation
function to
determine what is the most likely class
right so we do a South Mac which is
basically multivariate like logistic
regression
but for here this is just how one would
download the data set so we're gonna
transform the data we're just gonna
first scale it so that gets it all
centered but our training set is going
to come from the CFR ten data set it's
going to put it in a specific folder
this is all other commands you want it
to train it you want to download it if
you don't have it and you want to make
sure that you transform it using the
transform that we just described this
builds it and then the same thing with
the test that we're going to download
the test set but we're not going to
train it right because that's the whole
point having a test that is to see how
well it responds and here are the times
so far the C part n is I think Canadian
Institute for Advanced Research or
something like that and it just had ten
classes and these are the ten classes
so this is just getting us to see what
are the images in there so ship have no
it plane I'm no idea it's a frog or a
bird because these are the classes right
it's either cat bird deer dog frog horse
okay let's find out
well I guess we could find out what the
true values are right here that's a bird
okay it's hard to tell on this on the
resolution here
oh my laptop it's like a little bit
better but it's smaller as well so we're
gonna create the exact same thing that
we did for C far so we could download it
etc and I'm gonna say well it's not
Allen let's just literally create it
I'll do it from scratch so we're gonna
pass it through a convolutional layer
here are the input sizes we're gonna max
poulos we're going to do a two by two
max balloon which we're going to zoom in
on certain features and get things at
different levels of magnification pass
it through a second competition alone
tonight and then pass it through a sorry
fully connect layer a fully connected
layer and then we're then going to be
doing the forward pass is a little
different because the forward passes
were first into the activation right so
I pass the convolution through a RAL you
and then do the max pooling which is
this is where I said it's gonna get a
little more complicated but we will have
one that turns on that I will be more
than happy to guide you and then take
the second convolution again once you go
through the convolution do the r lu and
do the max pooling there's two ways to
do reshape the n pi dot reshape is dot
view or dot reshape so i put both you
guys actually see what it does and it
says we're going to reshape it to be the
size which is the size of the pixels
size of the images and then we're gonna
say where i pass it through the living
layer do a riley reactivation pass it
through the second fully connected Larry
to arrive early activation and then just
output the information out and then
return acts
so can you repeat the question so you if
it's so the thing is if your tensor is
defining you GPU you need to transfer it
to the CPU and there is a two CPU
function dot method that's two CPU that
handles that for you yeah it's yeah
basically there's a dot two numpy tensor
there's a dot two GPU
again the longer version of this
tutorial covers a little bit of that and
then you can get it get it for my github
back to you all the slides of there it's
just it's 90 minutes it's hard to rhyme
in all of that so let's run this guy
here create our so called image net and
we're going to just pass this to the 3d
Fox because it actually takes quite a
little bit of time but we'll see we pass
it through three times it's a very basic
sort of classification or neural net
right we've had one two convolution
followed by max put with the max pooling
rather activation connected layer and
then we output the more common one
resident 34 and read that 50 those are
34 and 50 layer neural Nets this is just
one they're not too
I I'm with you on that it's very
frustrating because really it's just how
hard if you start looking through the
convolutions if you think you have
enough convolutions you might need to
pass it through a few nonlinear fully
collected layers start getting a little
bit more of the nuance instead of trying
to capture images so it's just sort of a
fine-tuning of the weight which is what
we kind of do in transfer learning so
there is no rhyme or reason but we just
know it works so we continue using that
method it's not the best answer but I
know sometimes you'll have one sometimes
you'll have three and transfer or
anything we just chop off two and insert
new ones but the cut once the thing is
that once your convolutional layers are
trained you don't need to train it again
they're already captured all the things
you need you just now need to fine-tune
the very last piece and that fine-tuning
depending on the complexity of it might
require more fully connected layers
go through three passes and then we're
gonna check to see how this does right
so we actually created CFR time I just
showed you the code we're then gonna go
into little transfer learning then we're
gonna have you guys code one yourselves
and I'm happy to walk around and help
you guys out I just wanted to see how
this does there are ten types of classes
right the ship cat bird whatever well if
I randomly guessed a class I'll get it
right one in ten on average so if our
model does better than 10% we're
actually being able to capture something
that's even the essence of the data so
anything better than 10% is good we've
done three layers and we want to find
out how good this does just by passing
it so by doing three little training
sets like three little training key box
there we go all right so here are the
images cat for a ship ship plane right
so this is the ground truth let's look
at what our model told us so we
predicted cat for some reason it thinks
the second one is a car not a ship and
it thinks the ship in its plane so like
I said we were able to get these to be
right but that could have just been pure
luck we said anything over 10% is better
than a random guys so we trained this
with three layers sorry three epochs and
we got 50% accuracy just by doing three
simple epochs using this data set
there's six thousand sixty thousand
images total
[Music]
well the ruddy function does give you
some nonlinearities remember because if
the weight is negative sends you well
but if the weight is negative it flips
it we always think of the leaker of the
lu lu as being zero if it's negative and
then just a line if it's not but if i
got a negative weight i now have
different things where some of the
negative things get activated or not
plus I have my bias term to shift up and
down the block so I do get some hole in
your hair it's a random image generator
it pickup pulls in which is random oh
then it's just the exact same weight is
it the like if you do it again you get
the same images or if you run it one
more time do you get the exact same
images it should just be sort of the
pseudo-random number and in the back
yeah might be the seed
all right so this is a sort of
rapid-fire tutorial so the convolution
function is really just scanning so
basically imagine putting a matrix or
like a box over this image and you're
doing calculations based on some weight
that that convolution has to reduce the
dimension reducing the dimension getting
things that different features are
getting different types of layers out so
a convolution is just reducing the
dimension via some function that just
scans the whole image and reduces the
size because you get things you get
features at different scales
right because if I have a picture of a
dog that's quite big and then I have a
feature of a dog that's much smaller
because it's in the background I'm still
able trying to I want to look at things
at different features so I can capture
what is the dog regardless of the size
of the image or where it is an image you
want to make sure that you're getting
things at different scales I don't know
if it's clarity you just want to start
getting nonlinear feet like nonlinear
features and determine what is the
essence of this image you add different
scales so I don't know if it's clarity
per se but I know that it's a nice
little way to think about it as the
convolutions are giving you things in
different scales so then going quickly
into transfer learning right it was one
of the nicer things that we've seen in
machine learning right in the late 90s
someone said hey I've already spent all
this time training a model if I'm going
from an image task to an image task why
do I need to train the entire thing
again from scratch why can't I use the
sort of hidden layers and then just kind
of add a couple little layers at the end
to do the fine-tuning of the weights to
get the right classes out so I think
imagenet from Google took well over 24
hours to Train using Google like
resources they had 2000 different
classes they had millions and millions
of images but once you start getting
patterns these patterns don't change
right so a circle is still a circle
whether it's a circle on a car wheel or
a plane wheel or or a ball right the
image that we're trying to just capture
all these different things and then say
hey we start we want to capture these
different features but now fine-tune it
so that you give me the right class at
the end for taking a sidestep really
quick this is from that article that I
was mentioning visualizing and under
convolutional neural Nets this is the
third layer the first layer like I
mentioned it's just lines right got
lines going this way it's got lines
going this way if it can only do linear
functions but by the third layer in a
convolutional neural net it's starting
to actually get very very complicated
patterns so it's starting to notice
these sort of mosaic like patterns from
the images right so this was what had
activated that you start getting if the
spots on a Beatle right so it starts
generating spots it starts noticing what
is the outlines of humans I have no idea
what shells right it starts care
recognizing what what looks like a
billboard or a sign with text in it so
they could start going through many
different layers right so resident 50
has 50 of these layers so it starts
getting a lot of different complexities
and then since you've got so many
different parameters you start wiggling
through the neural net until you get to
the right class hopefully and that's
what the whole point of we're training
for but in transfer learning going back
to that right we've got all of these
parameters right we've got all these
layers that we know capture things that
are in images right I would say that if
you're training your model to unlink
ResNet or sort of like image net where
you have 2,000 different classes of what
Google like you know cats dogs etc and
then you say hey I want to look at this
to look at like cells under a microscope
like those sorts of images won't miss it
transferred that might not good be a
good transfer learning problem but if
you go in a I want to recognize this to
this and they're sort of in the same
vein of something that you would take
with the photograph of people or the
real world transfer learning actually
quite well so we transfer those
parameters over and then we change the
connected layers at the end to fine-tune
those weights so this is frozen foreign
Network B so this is the one that Google
did for example and so today there's two
thousand classes here as an output of a
lot of one mm tosses I want to determine
two different things which we'll get
into in just a second but I want to take
all of the knowledge that it had because
it takes a really long time to train
this because of its slow process got a
maneuver through the entire landscape
using gradient descent you could get
trapped in local
quite a bit so it says hey no they've
already done the hard part let's just do
the fine-tuning at the end so now by
using that we don't have to have
millions of images I could just have a
few hundred and say hey now I can
generate I can determine these sorts of
things using the transfer learning model
and it saves the reduces the tub the
computational complexity dramatically
right so since we're in Miami you wanted
to check to see if we could determine
using a transfer learning the difference
between the two king and queen of food
here we've got the famous Cuban sandwich
and the stuff that ever got to pay a
little homage to the home city
so I'm actually hot Cuban half Colombian
so these are full things I eat all the
time right
so this is very similar to what we did
for the CFR we're going to be doing some
sort of data transform we're going to be
loading it from a train set in a
validation set unfortunately you guys
look you could have access to the shell
system that behind the Google collab you
just have to do the magic like
exclamation point LS but if this was in
your shelter nor you would say hey what
is that word are all in these folders
you'd go to data there's data there's a
training validation it has each of those
images there's roughly about 250 total
images of each not that much right
remember image that was trained on
millions of images and now we're using
250 and we're going to do pretty darn
good so what we do here though which is
a little bit different than I did before
this I want to talk about because these
transformations are ways that you add
randomness so if I only have 250 images
and I want to make sure that I get you
know a dog looks like a dog but if I
only have dogs facing to the left
I'll never recognize a dog facing to the
right right just the image that was the
neural net will not captured I also want
to think hey how about if I look at it
from a different angle
all right so these transformations here
said you've all the resizes standard you
always wanted to just be a square random
a fine so you're basically going to do
in a half line projection and sort of
projected from a top view in a sense
then I want to maybe do a horizontal
flip and say hey change it because I
don't want my Cuban sandwich facing left
I want it facing right because you know
some people have thinking that way and
then we obviously do pencil
[Music]
so for here we're actually gonna use the
resident 50 nice this is gonna come
we're gonna take the resident 50 I'll
get you to your question in just a
second take resident 50 we're gonna
download it use the pre-trained version
so that we don't have to touch any of
the weight and we're just going to add a
layer at the end the rest of the layers
are frozen and do fine tuning to go from
those 2000 classes that Google had to
just say hey to give me an F or Cuban
sandwich it's a down sampling because it
just takes too long the images are huge
right especially if you have high
quality images right there's no reason
to use 1080p to do image clock
recognition it does it very well on low
res images yeah you get what what what
the reason why is that the quality
itself isn't the important part it's the
variety right so that's why we do the
transformation cuz well to 24 by 2 24
images is probably good enough right
there's plenty of pixels in there but I
want to make sure that I'm getting the
variety of getting top views like swipe
use you could even do things like
especially fast AI has this where you
can add like a sort of light like as if
you had to shone light on a specific
part of the image and they've got a
they've got at least 10 to 15 different
transformations that mimic what's really
happening with the real world and how we
see things right there's a difference
between looking at a pat from the bottom
up and then from the top down so they've
got all these nice little ways to do it
but I just kind of started it off with
some basic ones right randomly flip it
and randomly give me a projection of it
no no those were just two examples of
the many images I have yeah stretch them
yeah it's like a pie projection
you should well that would change the
task because there's a difference
between saying they say hey what is this
image and then the other one which is
tell me what is in this image which is a
slightly different task fall together so
I'm assuming for an image recognition
task that we're doing every image has
exactly that thing and nothing else but
if we had done a neighborhood called
that sort of pig jumping segmentation
task
I'm tired up I took a red-eye you want
to make sure that we're getting we're
trying to it's a different problem
altogether it's a different architecture
just outside if it's easier on
convocation all right so we're so we've
got our model right so here is where we
basically tell it to freeze those
parameters right I basically say for the
parameter in this model that has not
been changed don't require gradient
meaning decorating with those parameters
are frozen and then we're gonna add a
fully connected layer at the very end
with a relative activation
right then we do our typical stuff right
cross entropy loss
this is actually fairly quick because
we're doing food and out instead of
secretion right off the bat we're at 89%
accuracy on the validation set and
that's to me the one that that I care
about but we do jump up and down
remember this is we can modify this by
changing the learning rate changing the
number of epochs let's see I tend to do
fairly well we could have just
accidentally started hit a good point
yeah yeah let's see what happens so um
I'm not gonna save this model but we
could save models right so there are
many times where you say hey I've got to
this level of accuracy I don't know if
doing a few more rounds or training will
help let me save my model at this stage
because I can always undo it by loading
the model there are two ways to the load
models and pie charts this is one of
them and I think sort of the the one
that's less memory intensive you can
just save the entire model itself with
small parameters it's sort of like all
but what I'm basically doing here is
models saving the model weights only
right so it's kind of like the
difference between pickling and saving
through a dictionary there's a pil yeah
alright that's that that error is fixed
by re running the line all the way at
the top that says fixes error on Google
collab from earlier version of Pio
perfect but but I didn't expect you guys
to read that yeah you basically have to
restart your kernel just an FYI you have
to restart your kernel run those two
lines
well actually run the first three lines
except for the the PI torch installation
that works too I don't know I yeah I
know that I just basically gave me the
violence related version and I know that
it worked where am I
we're almost done with this right yeah
so this is done we can save them all
loading the model when you save it as a
dictionary is a little bit different
because if I had load that if I'd save
the model just like like a pickle type
file I would just load that model file
no problem and it'd be exactly where it
left off but when you save it as a dick
you need to load it by first creating
the architecture of the model saying hey
here is what my neural net is how its
defined what are the layers and then I'd
say here pass these weights to it and no
need to Train
[Music]
so it just basically goes from a fully
connected layer to there it's trying to
then do the fine-tuning at the very end
so sometimes I use the word chops off a
layer really it just stacks the output
from the original one no right because I
mean they only care about two classes so
yes I got all of these different thing
all of these different late outputs from
before but now I'm going to pass them
through more fully connected layers to
give me back at the ultimate
yeah as long as you added layer to the
end right so let's see how our model is
performing I'm not going to load the
version that I had already saved I want
to see how this one did at 72 percent
accuracy so here are some actual test
cases as your question so does it only
those two no there's actually more
so here's an idea that it says 99%
confident it was Anna depa eighty-six
percent confident this is a Cuban
sandwich
this is 76 percent confident is there
any applause and then 99 percent
confidence in it episode she says that
it was really well and I'll show you the
difference between that one and then the
model that I had before so I'm going to
load my old model yeah I guess a and
you'll see that the actual changes these
are all correct now so I still got a tip
on Cuban Cuban adapt oh but with
different percentage right because of
the weights I must have hit a different
or yeah yeah so this is one where it's a
little tough we are in Miami this Cuban
sandwich is around the corner everywhere
the one that says import pillow-like pip
install and you need to restart your
kernel so it's kind of a twofer so I'm
gonna ask you guys a question because I
can either keep on talking and show you
more examples or make it hands-on
because given the fact that this was a
90 minute tutorial and there's supposed
to be some Q&A at the end I can either
go briefly into our ends and show you
how our and ends work and then show you
like a loaded model or we want to get
hands-on with a CNN and then
alright so CNN's from scratch we're
gonna skip all together it's basically
building your own but if you guys pull
this from my github tomorrow you'll have
the solutions on there
[Music]
so the nice way to sort of familiarize
yourself with our intends is to start
looking at things like with character
lover generation or or language models
of in general tend to work very well
with RNs
and what we trying to do with an RNN or
actually with this with a language model
in general is say hey here is this piece
of text the quick brown junk the quick
brown fox jumped over the lazy and then
our model should be outputting the final
part of that right it should be
outputting space do G but what sets
apart an RNN from well on vanilla RNN
right we can cut into lsdm later but
what a vanilla RNN from under all that
so they really are neural net but where
the previous layer feeds into as an
input for for the current layer so it's
the output of this so this basically
says here's my input right well however
big it is pass this through this model
give me this output but pass some hidden
information about this here as well as
this output into there as well so this
sort of records on itself the reason why
there's this little recurring arrow that
you can actually unroll this and say no
for every single input I'm still going
to be using this this information going
down into my R and M as well so let's
look at this going forward right so
we're gonna be thinking it from a
character level generation it makes it
it makes a sort of the dimensionality a
lot easier to handle there's only
there's only like what let's say 80
types of characters including upper case
lower case but if we went to words and
we clearly blow up into a much higher
dimensional space so you can think of
this as being the word
or the letter sorry the letter
corresponding to the first input which
would be
right it goes through this model it has
a probability of what the next word is
that part that that information gets
passed on to the second then it sees the
H it says well what's my prediction
right and it's all this time it's going
through this just like I did the neural
net right it just has to happen it just
always has a information from the past
feeding into it instead of being it from
the immediate layer behind it so that's
really one of the key differences
between a regular neural net is that the
neural net that says hey what happened
immediately before this this layer and
that's all I care about
because I don't have information that
trickles from the past and that's why
they came up with our own ends is how do
we have this information keep on going
through from the from much earlier
layers till still feed into my current
layer so how does this p1 this
prediction help with p5 I can't do that
with a regular one so that's why we had
they created our own ends and then some
variations of it LS TMS and gos LS the
end times for long short-term memory and
G are used gated recurrent unit they're
quite similar they're just the
architecture a little different and how
they forget information and like with
any neural net once you define a forward
path you have to have some sort of way
to calculate the backward paths which
has the gradient calculation as well so
it's a little bit more involved so this
is a sort of a visualization but we will
forward to the neural net to go back
through the gradients and update each of
these weights and remember these weights
are then feeding through the hidden
layers block so I'll go into the steps
here of how this is done there's
obviously going to be a little bit of
pre-processing you want to make sure
that you take so what we're going to be
doing here is to give you a little bit
more context of like what the problem is
we're trying to solve is I have text
here from Shakespeare right and I want
to generate text that sounds like
Shakespeare but I need to take his text
and I can't take the whole thing right
because I'm going to run
memory issues but I'm gonna say I'm
gonna take chunks of it at a time
because I want to capture a little
nuance and his paragraphs instead of the
whole body of text right so in the in
the nuance I want to say hey I'm gonna
get like 400 strings so alright this is
the typical import for language this is
the entire file length is around 10,000
characters in this file and I'm gonna
generate a chunk length of 400
characters so that is going to be my
training site so my training input is
going to be 400 characters chosen
randomly from Shakespearean text 400
sequential characters so here I actually
started off with the loving the end of
us of a word but that's fine because
you'll notice here it actually it is
literally the play like you would see
Romeo you would see Julia and then the
part the key she sets one of the
beautiful things about this that it
actually starts generating names that
are legit from Shakespeare let's say hey
Romeo said this and it makes zero sense
but it's still got Romeo so it's
actually quite cool so this is just sort
of the pre-processing getting things set
up now we want to build that model again
our n ends are a little bit more
involved so we want to define these as a
class alright we've got an input size
hidden size right the output size and
the number of layers of the number of
hidden layers inheriting from the
superclass we've got this embedding
layer so this embedding layer says hey
how do we go from a much higher
dimensional space to reduce
dimensionality space without losing a
lot of the variants so think of like
work Tyvek or glove model this is the
same thing we've got a whole bunch of
words how do they relate it's that
famous King - man equals we yeah so if
we music linear algebra but it's really
just a wording budding at the lower
dimensional representation we define the
forward model I'll skip this for now
just because it could get a little bit
of all that I know we're running short
on time and you guys want to see a
little bit of things that we do here is
where we want to make sure that we talk
about what this car - tensor does
because we're not passing it the little
we are passing it the
character itself but under the hood it
has to have an index for that character
so in under the hood is just as it
passed index 0 on an alkane index oh and
so and that's the relationship between
the characters but that's not what we're
seeing so when we passed this this is
what we're going to be sending so if I
type in you know Metis 0 1 2 3 ABCs at
ABC it says oh yeah 18 below so 0 1 2 3
ABC z capital ABC sequentially it's just
ASCII characters right so then it says
hey when I caught in this index then
this could have been you know 10,000
different words it would just been a
bigger space but it would've been this
word is this index for our training set
right we're just gonna say for our
training set which is gonna take some
random chunk past that chunk from our
character tarter parts of character to
tenser and then the target is gonna be
the very last thing so we're gonna take
everything except the last character and
see if we can predict the last character
and then this is a little bit how we're
gonna evaluate that model so we're gonna
try to make it come up with new phrases
so we're gonna initialize our hidden
state our input is going to be this
Prime string right
excuse me right now it's just the letter
A right it could have been any string I
want to pass and it says hey take this
string pass it through our character two
tensor put it into my model and then
given what you've learned about
Shakespeare and this phrase that I just
passed you generate what comes next
right but it's gonna be a little bit
different because we wanted to have
really some variety so we need to have
some sort of probabilistic input in here
so I'll skip this first time here but
once I have in in my length right so as
I'm still predicting new words right so
I have a predict length of 100 I'm gonna
be passing this through my model and
saying okay here's my input here's my
hidden and then I want to make sure that
I get from a multinomial distribution
because I don't always want it to say
hey the most common thing the path that
comes after T is H that's the most
common one but it's not always the woman
right I want it to be give me some sort
of randomness so from this probability
distribution or in this case a
multinomial distribution pick something
where this temperature or the randomness
the higher the summer is the crazier the
prediction will be the smaller that
number is the tighter that prediction
will be introduction Chester generates
quite monotone sentences and I'll show
you a little bit what that looks like
all right so we go through all that and
we predict I don't think I've ran this
yet
this is just a training part I'm going
to avoid this for now because I actually
have these models loaded right so we
don't have to train the back to you but
this trains for quite a while like I
train this for like ten thousand two
thousand three thousand epochs it's a
very long time especially if it's on
your CPU but I've got two models here
I've got a POTUS dot pine torch and a
Shakespeare about light source so I
trained text using Trump's tweets from
like Elton to like half of 2018 or
whatever right so and then I train the
Shakespeare model that we've seen right
now so right now we're gonna have a kind
of we want it to be a little bit sort of
giving us a little bit more diversity
which is why the temperatures a little
higher so I can pass this thing here so
I say I'm gonna give it this phrase and
I say molar which hunt
all right so it does sometimes make
sense sometimes it doesn't I think the
temperature might be a little high if
you bring this a little lower yeah like
this one I know
oh I love this it generates a clickable
link it generates random Twitter links
it is a legit clickable hyperlink that
does not exist it says every you know
Trump tends to give hyperlinks to things
and they're usually URL shortened yeah
so I've actually I passed this my
dissertation which was written in LASIK
I don't have it here but it actually
closes equations it says begin equation
end equation it does align right it'll
it'll jump times generate legit like
come compilable a tech this is what
making sense there's no actual equation
there but it actually generates these
things and then for billy wright really
Billy Shake to be or not to be the thing
and the will and the master and friends
are a man shall be speak to the masker
and therefore in to be men then my lord
until you have will hear his hands that
he here his fling and in his those are
all legit words they just don't make
sense but well one speaks Old English
one piece trying to understand
pick something and why is it that so
would be for to capture the information
are an N conceivably try to figure out
why it reaches that point not
necessarily visualize just more I think
for me personally language models have
always been hard hard to define the why
because it's incredible right so there's
actually this link right here the
unreasonable effectiveness of neural
nets is where I got the inspiration for
for what I did today
Andrew Karpov II yeah wrote about how we
just don't get it but it works he
actually got Linux source code and
generated Linux source code using we're
using numerical data I'm not sure yeah
that's right I know that from what I
mostly use our own ends for language
yeah I know there were a little well I'm
happy to stay and answer questions I
don't know if they're gonna kick me out
though but it was a full three and happy
to stay here long what about like both
stuff now how this differs from these
talking about third for NLP the
adversarial network
[Music]
yeah so I can't I know Burt just
recently was an out like was published I
haven't read that paper yet and I don't
know enough about our actual reporters
but for Ganz you're basically trying to
have like a cop versus Robert you're
basically a fraudster versus the person
trying to catch a frog foster right so
you're basically pulling these back and
forth ganz in general are ridiculously
tough to train because it works off it
starts off with just random noise and it
takes a really long time for it to get
out of that roll and go into but this
but the gans are gonna be doing a lot
more image so this is what you see with
with Vegas or whatever like yeah I I
don't know I thought I might have to go
a little bit deeper into it but but I
know that they've done a sweep it does
it basically Tunes them independently
okay so it says I've trained this model
right now pass it to the discriminator
this just says hey this is fake this is
real I tried to get as good as possible
and then I paid that information pass it
to the generator do the exact same thing
again right and that's how your
fine-tuning to get to things where I
can't like I can sometimes even tell the
news I don't know if you guys saw the
latest one of some of the real fake
celebrities they look legit people that
I was going yeah that's a real human
being
yeah whoa I was gonna take a giant I I
don't think there's an advantage that I
think they they have different
applications I think so CNN's are really
useful for like static things like an
image it's static it's not changing in
time which is I don't so a CNN I don't
need to learn from the past right an RN
and Gus because an RNN says hey what my
current state is right now was modified
by what happened in the past and I need
to know I need to have information from
the past trickle in for a CNN it's just
I just have this image right I'm just
I'm trying to get the nuance of this
image but it's not changing in time it's
not evolving I if they do I personally
never yeah it might be to track off this
time to kind of become the combination
of tracking your neighbors over time
into private partner
[Music]
[Applause]